are you ready Mike ready Mitchel go kiss
the cock ring on Dirk Diggler
yes I'll be very careful he is very
sensitive okay be careful he does have
to keep it long for quite a bit of time
there that's almost about fakest the one
in the movie Jeter's come on come on who
has little son there
Mitchell Mitchell is our winner now
you're done stop it stop it
Mitchell come over here you are with us
Babette Mitchell is or whether you get
the 20 extra points get away from me I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and this is pop
quiz hotshot I'm the Nostalgia Critic
and ever since I was a child I always
want to play games quoting movies and TV
with my friends the only problem was I
had no friends well now that I have
power I can take my friends by force
with the help of my new pal general
anaesthetic I can kidnap all the friends
I want and force them to answer
questions in might Saved by the Bell
style cent there will be laughs trivia
those disturbing cartoons that give you
night terrors but most of all there will
be fun the laughter and joy will last
however long I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
and welcome to pop quiz hotshot proof
once again that madness doesn't die it
just takes a little break our
contestants today are Mitchell and Mike
Mitchell it says here that you play 12
different instruments
I get bored can you name them all in 10
seconds handbells hands no I know French
my trumpet clarinet Tromso guitar guitar
Wow okay but you missed the part here
where you supposed to do it
alphabetically so sadly we're gonna have
to pierce some part of you that hesitant
Piercy Oh which would be tricky but
we'll make do Mike it says here that you
are a stand-up I've been I've been known
to dabble
yeah I've been also been known to do
stand-up yeah I'm not gonna lie with
that beard you kind of look like the
person Stan that's what make fun of well
and a lot of material you must be great
at your job and I just have to point out
kiss I saw them earlier you have a
tattoo of a coupon on your arm don't you
yeah I guess so this is gonna be fun
all right we're gonna find out how this
game is played general anesthetic why
don't you tell us each contestant is
asked a series of questions involving
the sounds of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the nostalgia critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes get even harder the winner with
the most points face off against the
nostalgia critic and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
okay you both ready yellow karate okay
Mitchell in Tootsie what actor said I
was a better man with you as a woman
than I ever was with a woman it's a man
little miss sunshine so close I mean
like this close Dustin Hoffman Mike
which Harrison Ford movie had the line I
have a head for business and a bod for
sin is there anything wrong with that a
nightmare before christmas again closely
it was actually Star Wars everyone
forgets about that cut it was another
Lucas rendition no it was working girls
Mitchell finish this John Cusack live
from say anything I gave her my heart
and she gave me a STD I'm giving you the
points on that one my friend because
that's that would have been a very
different movie though not that
different it was pretty heavy Mike in
ghostbusters who said they caused an
explosion the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
you get like one life
I speak stay-puft they translate out to
they cause an explosion m-maybe as we
said when you blow up their cars are
explosion given that given the points
for creativity that does pre-created
mitchell in blade which actors said some
of the fuckers always trying to ice
skate up him mr. Keane you know the
movies called blade if you literally
repeated the title I probably will have
given you the points but I might give
you the points if you can just say one
line from any of the mr. t PSAs a pity
the fool given the points as Mike in
tombstone what character told Johnny
Ringo I'm your huckleberry oh that would
be walter mondale and i'm a gonna answer
that just don't give up
Mitchell finish this line from takin I
can tell you I don't have money but what
I do have are a very particular set of
testicles he does but it's not the right
answer
it is skills which it's kind of the same
answer but nevertheless I'm not kick you
to the point Mike which movie had the
line I have come here to chew bubblegum
and kick ass and I'm all out of
bubblegum big trouble mucho
actually they live I heard so many
people gasp bet they're like oh I really
thought it was that too and do those two
get confused are they that similar
Mitchell what famous movie character
asked I know what you're thinking did he
fire six shots or only five
Raymond this is amazing somehow there's
50 points between the two of you and not
one if you have actually gotten a right
answer yet no Turney Harry Mike what
Christmas movie had the line Frazee Lane
must be Italian a Christmas story yes
yay
you will plot none of them you'll only
applaud the fact that we all have
eyewear on in this episode oh that's
really weird that might be the first
time Mitchell named the movie with the
following line this is extremely
important will you please tell Santa
that instead of presents this year I
just want my family back
is the answer my childhood videos you
clearly told me the wrong interesting
thing about you go outside for the
twelve instruments give him the points
for the Hat
Mike what will Ferrell characters said
first we'll make snow angels for two
hours then we'll go ice skating then
we'll eat a whole roll of Tollhouse
cookie dough as fast as we can and then
we'll snuggle elf oh I'm so glad you got
that right because that was a really
long one to read you you don't look like
an elf person I'm surprised you liked
that movie and say I like the movie you
just remember that incredibly long
complicated line
it's my mantra yeah you'll get your next
tattoo with that I'm sure Mitchell in
pee-wee's big adventure which character
said be sure to tell him Large Marge
sentient pee wee himself it's the
question if I said something mm Greg
sent you what would you say pee-wee
Herman
may those earrings are like pulling your
brain out or something Mike
in Amadeus who is Salieri talking to
when he says from now on we're enemies
you and I because you choose for your
instrument of both full lustful smutty
infantile boy elf I just I can't what
what incredible movie that would be if
elf was in it well middle of a joke okay
they of course was the spazzy attack it
looks like Mitchell has avoided it well
done and it's so sorry to say that elf
you need to pay the penalty is a penalty
of my choosing and I'm getting a joker
vibe out of you no no I'm not we just
have a joker costume so you're gonna be
Heath Ledger's Joker so as we get you
dressed up for that
Mitchell you get to watch the Spacey
cartoon oh now Elizabeth don't make up
such tales don't you know I'm allergic
to singing blood that is the most
disturbing thing I've ever seen ah until
I saw that wow you look like ZZ Top
passed out and somebody to stuff on your
face I feel like don't worry you look
brilliant and I'm sure you'll prove your
brilliance in round two where the
questions get a little harder or in your
case probably the exact same so let's
start with Joker Mike finish this line
from Schindler's List I cannot wait to
hear the Joker answered vessel
the list is an absolute good the list is
delicious
given the poisonous that is what the
Joker would say Mitchell you to him
obviously it's a sink over here right
now huh Mitchell which might judge film
did this line come from every day gets
worse than the last that way every day
is the worst day of my life
Magic Mike did you just hear Mike Judge
you're just like Mike that makes me
think of the movie Magic Mike and you
just throw it in there yes
no I don't know or did he really direct
Magic Mike did he track that I'm gonna
say you're wrong so no no point for you
Mike finish this to me Mike's today I'm
just sick of saying Mike I can get rid
of some of them for you yeah so can i
Mike finish this infamous line from
Blazing Saddles excuse me while I tickle
your fancy you know I'm not gonna give
you the points because a whuppin fly if
you actually said the real line which is
whip this out Mitchell what film had the
line this is one time where television
really fails to capture the true
excitement of a large squirrel
predicting the weather Discovery Channel
documentary just that's what they call
it
oh just Discovery Channel documentary
they they're just like you know what
let's not be specific cuz we know nobody
really watches so let's just say
Discovery Channel documentary I'm glad
you understand no we're clearly on the
same page because I saw it wasn't it
good it was very good yeah that one
documentary with Bill Murray you know he
repeats the same day and everything
everyone thinks it was just a fictional
film called Groundhog Day but no it was
a documentary just called Discovery
Channel documentary now
so looking forward to killing you Mike
in the King of Comedy what characters
said it's fair to be king for a night
that a schmuck for a lifetime Bernie Mac
you know that that worked on two levels
one it's the wrong King of Comedy and
two just any time you smack your lips
like that that's just irresistible give
him the points the answer was actually
Rupert Pupkin which also would have been
very funny coming out of the Joker
Mitchell
finish this Air Force One line get off
my dick was the physical challenge just
ringing in your head there I they okay
yeah yeah it's good I would just love to
hear Harrison Ford say get off my deck
please put them the new Star Wars movie
that would be amazing Mike in The Return
of the King what character says my
friends you bow to no one the giant
spider if you said that as the Tim Curry
clown maybe I won't given you some boys
but no it was actually Agosto it was
actually Eragon which is actually kind
of the name of an original spider from
Harry Potter which didn't rip anything
off at all don't kill me email Mitchell
who directed the movie with the tagline
and adventures 65 million years in the
making my very old great grandmother yes
yes it was your very old great
grandmother Steven Spielberg wait if
you're very old great grandmother not
Steven Spielberg No then you're wrong
Mike which spider-man villain said I
didn't choose to be this the only thing
left of me now is my daughter Green
Goblin I can understand you not getting
that right DC Marvel and stuff like that
and I can also understand it because it
was from spider-man 3 which everyone who
saw it just immediately erased it from
their mind because it's so horrible it
was actually the Sandman Mitchell finish
the line from Mission Impossible you
find something that's personally
important to him and
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun Oh Oh critic
Mitchell critic Mitchell Mitchell
Mitchell no mic which movies first line
of dialogue here you are sir
main level please is spoken around 25
minutes after the film begins this is
the hardest question I've ever read
I could be amazed babe see you know I'll
give you the points cuz I love the idea
that Joker saw babe take in the city
that's just that's adorable and kind of
fitting if you know how screwed up that
movie actually is the answer is 2001 a
Space Odyssey very similar films
Mitchell which Mel Brooks movie contains
the line leave us alone Mel Brooks my
8th grade sleepover you're getting more
and more surreal as the night goes on
but you know what the fine thing is if
somebody told me hey which one of these
in the middle of the show was in costume
I wouldn't be able to tell them
it was actually Robin Hood Men in Tights
oh it isn't a movie and you did it dis
justice by not getting it right no I
will give you know this is the weirdest
wardrobe man I've ever seen on the show
Thank You general asset I wanted to keep
my disease a secret you may continue
thank you thank you Mike which movie
featured a charismatic leader asking a
crowd of ruffians can you dig it
ace
keep going you'll get a laugh do
something else random Mitchell which Tom
Hanks characters said I'm pretty tired I
think I'll go home now after running for
three years Forrest Gump yes and that
means that the round is over and by 10
points Mitchell wins very nice nicely
done sadly Mike that means that you must
have bullets put in you never know put
some extra bullets in him Mitchell you
are making it to the final round which
we will get to right after this if you
would like to be a contestant a pop quiz
hotshot and live in the Chicagoland area
send a video via YouTube stating your
name a and why do you think you would be
a good confession
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Mitchel
congratulations you'll be battling
against in the south a critic in our
final round of reading off seven
questions
Mitchell if you beat the critic in this
round you'll win this an entire army of
posters featuring entire armies also
$100 in cash and of course you're alive
I've got to get me one of those all
right I'm gonna be reading a series of
Blues Brothers quotes you'll have to
identify what not the line is spoken by
either Jake or Elwood let's begin
Mitchell it's one of your six miles in
Chicago we've got a full tank of gas a
half pack of cigarettes it's dark and
we're wearing sunglasses incorrect
critic I hate Illinois Nazis Jake
correct
Mitchell well thank you pal the day I
got out of prison my own brother picks
you up in a police car Jake correct
critic and we would especially like to
welcome all representatives of
Illinois's law enforcement community
that have chosen to join us here at the
palace hotel ballroom at this time Helen
correct Mitchell
well then I guess you're really up shit
creek okay correct critic signify your
feelings with every gentle caress
because it's so important to have that
special somebody to hold to kiss to miss
to squeeze and please knowin correct
Mitchell you can't lie to a nun we've
got to go in and visit the penguin Helen
correct critic oh please don't kill us
please please don't kill us I know you
love you baby I wouldn't leave yet it
wasn't my fault chick correct
Mitchell hey that's where they got that
Picasso
hello Kirk incorrect critic no ma'am
were musicians Hill would correct
Mitchell how much for that little girl
how much were the women okay
correct critic they don't have my
address I falsified my renewal I've put
down 1060 West Addison no way correct
Mitchell yes yes Jesus age tap-dancing
Christ Helen incorrect and critic who is
that girl
Helen correct and winner is
[Music]
I'm so sorry you see on the scoreboard
there I am the winner it's the way it is
oh oh I guess you're the winner now
that's a shame gets away might have to
okay I guess you gotta leave me off in
runaway time better give me that back
I am the winner here take them on to my
synagogue Imam yes you don't know you
don't wanna do that you know I'll do
that easy
he's only gonna make things worse he's
making things worse for him how
wonderful
well I'm in this town jerk rake and I'll
see you next time on pop quiz hotshot
beeping oh absolutely I think you know I
have to admit this was probably the most
normal looking contestant we've ever had
pretty much yeah I mean I really
couldn't tell which one was in the
caption and which one wasn't
well absolutely obsessed I think
therefore pick apples flaws nor to
confuse me but I always get it worked
golly I really worked I was genuinely
confused by pretty much every single
answer they gave was like one right each
yeah I think so somehow they got 70 and
60 how does that work well that's your
rules
I guess it's my rules but you know what
I'm starting to rethink that maybe I
shouldn't do that
ah maybe we should make it like a
skating of the Stars show Yale revealed
not better my I'd like it yeah we can
just make this an ice rink just
everything a nice yeah yeah except we
can't really keep it cold so it'd just
be water well drown drowning of the
stuff there you go that's what I've read
that's right
[Music]